[Music]
welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with the growing
threat of violence against asian
americans since the beginning of the
pandemic more than 10 000 incidents of
physical violence or verbal harassment
against asian americans and pacific
islanders have been reported the
majority of those incidents nearly 60
percent take place in public spaces like
city streets and businesses that's led
one man to help seniors in his community
learn to defend themselves and as elaine
kejano reports for him the mission is
personal
hit nice they've been taunted and had
close calls but these asian-american
seniors never trained to defend
themselves until now
subdigenerians like new york city native
mary webb getting married
what do you think is the most important
thing that you've learned so far from
the class to be very aware
of your surroundings
and i'm always very aware but i do have
friends who are
older or younger they don't pay
attention
sami yan started teaching these
self-defense classes at new york city's
university settlement center after
someone told his dad who lives in boston
to go back to china he was just riding
the subway home and then you know
someone verbally assaulted him and his
friends what did you think when you
heard that i was really like disturbed
and bothered and kind of angry you know
that someone would um you know threaten
my father and i wish i was there and so
i just felt like i had to you know
help the people that i can here
in new york
armed with years of martial arts
training yen's objective is clear the
simple goal is just to empower the
students to be able to go outside to do
their tours go to work and just get home
safely be aware of threats before they
happen and give yourself time to get
away mary ewen now carries that
knowledge with her and gratitude for her
young teacher keeps her eyes on me
excellent very good what do you think of
sammy he's really wonderful he's very
dedicated he doesn't mind if you punch
him the wrong way
i don't know it's like oh my
honor honor sounds like you enjoyed that
a little bit
too much
for sammy yet
helping elders protect themselves helps
him too yeah it's great i mean it really
makes it feel like it's worth it
you know teaching this class and be able
to give back to the community and every
time i leave here i'm very
pleased or happy and i feel like
something positive is happening powerful
response to a painful reality
for cbs saturday morning elaine quijano
new york
you hope they never have to use it but
that's empowering just to know what you
could do and i i think mary said it best
there at the top of the piece so elaine
talked to she said just be aware right
right and sort of know what's going on
and also your posture says so much yeah
so you walk around like don't mess with
me
that's that's like your position
does all the time
i'm not messing with you
like uh
yeah like a power stance don't come from
me
like this is what we do like jeff just
shows off the gun yeah we should show
the guns